♪ [music] ♪
In these last few sessions, we've
talked about how to value a company.
And we said the value of a company is a
function of its cash flows, its growth,
and its risk. That's what a discounted
cash flow valuation tries to do is bring
those numbers into a number you
attach to the company. In this session,
we're going to talk about a much more
common way of attaching a number
to a company, and that is to price
the company. You're saying, "What
does that mean?" Well, let's
talk about it. When you talk
about pricing a company,
here's what you're doing.
You're trying to attach a number to a
company based on how similar companies
are being priced out there. I'll
use the analogy of real estate.
Think about what you do when you buy
a house. A realtor shows you a house
and gives you a number for the house.
But that realtor comes up with the number
of the house based on how similar houses
have traded for or transacted for in the
recent past. That's what you're doing
in pricing, and if you break it down,
there are three parts to pricing. The
first is, you have to find comparable
or similar companies out in the market
that are traded because you need that
trading price. The second is, you've
got to convert that traded price into a
standardized price. Why? Because
price per share is not comparable
across companies, and here's why.
When I have a price per share of a $100,
I can very easily make it $50 per share
by doubling the number of shares,
having the stock split. That makes the
number of shares twice what it was before,
so I've got to standardize the price.
If you're mystified, in a second,
I'll fill in the details. So you've got
comparable assets of companies,
you've got a standardized price,
you compare those prices across the
companies. Then you make a judgment
call based on what your company looks
like relative to those
comparable companies.
So comparable companies, standardized
price, and storytelling make up what a
pricing is going to do.
So to take a look at that
standardized price, let me break it
down. In a standardized price,
here's what you would see.
You would see a multiple.
And in the numerator of the multiple,
you have some measure of market value.
And there are at least three variants you
might see. The first is the market value
of equity or market capitalization,
share price times number of shares.
You could see market value
of equity plus market value of debt,
which is the total value of the firm.
Or you might see, market value of equity
plus market value of debt minus cash,
which is called enterprise value.
All three are measures of market pricing
of value. In the denominator is where
you'll see the variance. You
could divide that market value that
you got for equity, the firm,
or in the enterprise by the revenues
of the business. Those revenues can either
be stated in dollar values or as drivers
of revenues, number of users,
number of subscribers.
So the first choice is to divide
the market value by revenues or
revenue drivers. You might divide
the market value by earnings.
Those earnings can either be to equity
investors, earnings per share or
net income. Or they can be to the
entire business, operating income.
You can divide by cash flows. Those
cash flows can either be EBITDA,
if you're looking at the operating assets
of company, or it can be net income
plus depreciation, which is a
measure of cash flow to equity.
Or you can divide by book
value, book value of equity,
which is the accountants measure of how
much the equity in the company is worth or
book value of the entire firm, which
is book value of equity plus book
value of debt, or what accountants
like to call invested capital, which is
book value of equity plus book value
of debt minus cash. In summary,
the numerator is always a market value.
The denominator is some kind of scaling
variable. So with that set up, let's
talk about the four steps in using
multiples right, or doing pricing well.
The first step, if you were to decide
to price your company rather than
to value it, is to make sure that you've
defined and understood the multiple
you're using. You're saying, "Well,
the multiple I'm using is PE, everybody
knows what the PE ratio is." You'd be
surprised how many variants there are
on commonly used multiples. So the first
step is define and make sure what
your multiple is okay. Second step,
describe the multiple. Sounds fancy,
right? But play some money ball.
Look at the distribution of your multiple
to get a sense of what it looks like.
Rather than use rules of thumb for high
numbers and low numbers, let the data
tell you what's high and what's low.
Third step, analyze the multiple.
Embedded in every multiple are all of the
assumptions about cash flows, growth,
and risk you're trying to run away from.
So make sure you bring them into the
comparison. And the final step, apply
the multiple. Define, describe, analyze,
apply. The key to doing pricing
right is to go through those steps
carefully every time you use a multiple.
So let's start with a definitional test.
When I look at a multiple, there
are two questions I always ask.
The first is, is this multiple
consistently defined?
And the second question is,
is it uniformly estimated?
Let me start with the first of those two
questions, is it consistently defined?
Here's a simple rule.
If your numerator is an equity value, your
denominator has to be an equity value
as well. If your numerator is a firm or
an enterprise value, your denominator is
to be a firm or an enterprise value
as well. You're mystified, right?
So let's take an example. Think
of PE ratios, the most widely used
multiples in the world. The numerator,
the price or market cap, is an equity
value. The denominator, earnings per
share or net income, is an equity value.
Thank God for small blessings.
The most widely used multiple
in the world passes the consistency
test. So in the consistency test,
you're checking the numerator and the
denominator. We'll do a couple more
examples of this in a
second, but that's a first stop.
The second stop is, remember,
you're comparing this multiple across 15
or 20 companies. Make sure you're
estimating the multiple the same way
for all 15 or 20 companies. You
know how difficult a test this is
to meet? Think about PE ratios.
What am I asking you to do?
I am asking you to make sure that the
earnings per share is estimated the same
way for all 15 and 20 companies.
So those are the two questions of the
definitional test. Let me use a couple
of examples to illustrate the consistency
point that I made. I already told
you price-earnings ratios are
consistent multiples, numerator
and denominator equity values.
That said though, it's amazing how many
variations you can get on the PE ratio
for a company. So if you take a company
like Coca-Cola and you ask me what the PE
ratio is, here's what's going to drive
differences across different investors
and analysts. In the numerator,
you usually have the current price
but I've seen some variance that
might use an average price over time.
It's in the denominator that you get the
real variations. I can divide the price
per share by earnings per share
in the most recent fiscal year.
That's called current PE. I could
divide price per share by earnings
per share in the last four quarters.
That's trailing PE. I could divide price
per share by expected earnings
per share in the next four quarters.
That's forward PE. Or I can even divide
price per share by expected earnings
per share in the year 2027. That's really,
really forward PE. You can have earnings
per share before extraordinary
items or after extraordinary items,
before option expensing or after option
expensing. I've told people that if you
take companies that are widely followed,
don't be surprised to see 15, 20, or 25
different numbers passing as PE
ratios for the company. You're saying,
"So what." Depending on your biases,
you're going to latch on to either the
lowest of those numbers or the highest
of those numbers, so watch out.
Here's a second example to illustrate the
consistency point. One of the most widely
used multiples now in equity research
is the EV to EBITDA multiple.
In the EV to EBITDA multiple,
here's what you're going to see.
In the numerator, you're going to see
market value of equity plus debt
minus cash, enterprise value.
And in the denominator,
you're going to see EBITDA. In fact,
think about it. Why am I netting
out cash? Because the interest income
from cash is not part of my EBITDA.
It's a consistency reason. In fact,
if you use that consistency reason,
you can already see that if you have
a company with cross holdings,
to get to an EV to EBITDA for the
company, you have to adjust
for those cross-holdings. So you have
minority holdings in other companies,
you got to net it out of the numerator
because the operating income from those
holdings are not part of your EBITDA.
If you have majority holdings, you might
have to add on the 40% or 45% or 50%
of the EBITDA of the cross holding that
hasn't been counted yet. It's a mess,
but it's a mess of your own doing.
So when you look at multiples, make
sure they're consistently defined.
Make sure they are uniformly estimated
because only then can you start using
them. So let's at least set up the second
step in the process. You've defined the
multiple, the next step is to look
at the distribution of these multiples.
Practice some basic statistics.
So if you look at PE ratios,
look at the distribution of PE
ratios using EV to EBITDA, look
at the distribution. Distribution
over what subsample?
Start up by looking at the distribution in
your own sector, but then look at the
distribution for the entire market.
You're going to be surprised at some
of those characteristics you discover
when you look at the distribution.
Let me illustrate by showing you PE
ratios at the start of 2014 for U.S.
companies. Notice that this distribution
has a peak to the left and a tail to the
right. That is actually typical of almost
all multiples. You're saying, "So what?"
Basically, the reason you have a peak
to the left and a tail to the right is
that PE ratio can
never be lower than zero.
So you have floated zero. It can
be any number at the other end
of the spectrum. What that does is,
when you compute averages for PE ratios,
they'll get pulled out by the positive
outliers. Here's the lesson I get
out of looking at this distribution.
When you ask me what the PE ratio for a
company is, I can never compare the PE
ratio for that company to the average
for the sector and draw a conclusion
because I might be drawing the
wrong conclusion. So I'm going to draw
on Stat 101. I was told that when I have
asymmetric distributions,
rather than use the average,
I should be using the median.
I'm going to draw on that lesson.
So if you ask me is Disney cheap
or expensive relative to other
entertainment companies, rather
than compare Disney's PE ratio
to the average for entertainment
companies, I'm going to compare it
to the median. Basic statistics, but it's
amazing how useful it is when you start
looking at the actual numbers
that underlie distributions.
So if you've decided to price your
company, here's what I'd like you
to start off with. Try to compute
different multiple for your company,
staying true to the notion of consistency.
So do a price to earnings ratio, do a
price to book ratio, try an EV
to EBITDA, try an EV to sales,
but don't do a price to sales or a price
to EBITDA. A price to EBITDA and a price
to sales would be internally inconsistent.
The numerator is an equity value,
the denominator is not.
Once you have these numbers,
you're on your pathway to actually pricing
your company rather than just valuing it.
♪ [music] ♪